people ask me right and and sisters ask
me Muslims ask him why do you do it my
first answer and I want everyone to
listen to me listening to me learn this
and may Allah put it in your heart as he
put it in mind and you say why you are
wearing your head cover or while you're
wearing your Islamic attire I say
because Allah asked me to do it period
and then they say is it a choice this is
the second question you always get and I
said it's your choice and mine to obey
Allah or not to obey him and I I need to
get be ready at the day of judgment when
I'm standing in front of him and I
better prepare a very good answer why I
chose naturally